greeting some podcast Vil the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by zip recruiter you know what smart
kicking off 2019 by playing out which
rolls your business desire for unlike
other job sites zip recruiter finds
qualified candidates for you
that's why zip recruit is rated number
one by employers in the US this rating
comes from hiring sites on trust pilot
with over a thousand reviews I don't
care how big your business is whether
it's small huge medium you could benefit
from zip recruited right now the church
family can't ride zip recruiter for free
zip recruiter for free that's right free
I'm starting a year off with free why
because I love you go to zip lacunae
comm slash Church if you love the show
show some support and let's zip britain
by going to zip recruiter dot-com slash
shirt CH you are CH is the place to be
that zipper cool.com slash church zip
recruiter comm slashed church listen
this podcast is also brought to you by
hims hims you know I like hymns because
it's the best thing out there going
you're looking at me go enjoy what are
you talking about I'll tell you what I'm
talking about
sixty-six percent of men lose their hair
by the age of 35 the thing is when you
start to notice hair loss it's too late
for hems calm is a one-stop shop for
hair loss skin care and sexual wellness
for men what they do is nice and easy no
drama thanks to science baldness could
be optional alright hims connects you
with real doctors and medical grade
solutions to treat hair loss with
well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair like I said they also
help with skin care and sexual wellness
and we know what I'm talking about but
do me a favor go to hims calm right now
for hims dot-com right now and take a
look there's no waiting rooms there's no
awkward in-person doctor visits right
now the church family
to trial month aims for five hours today
while supplies last see the website for
full details this would cost you
hundreds if you went to a doctor or a
pharmacy
I'm doing it for you for five hours for
the first month so go to four hems calm
slash Joey again that's four hems
dot-com slash Joey for five hours for
the first month while supplies last kick
this [ __ ] melee what up you bad
[ __ ] beautiful Monday that's
everybody's back to work the game is
over the hugs the [ __ ] stories the
apple cider the gifts now comes the
credit card bill how comes the credit
card know about 15th and your real
cracked but you know what who gives a
[ __ ] you have to spend some time with
your family your loved ones and it's
that time of the year where it's nice to
stop and smell the [ __ ] roses if you
have a rose we all have a rose Sam
Tripoli what up dude thanks fat me on I
love you and Happy New Year you happy
New Year to both of you relieved of a
[ __ ] Happy New Year happy anniversary on
a year doing stand-up you're killing it
dude
thank you very much below me the Sam
said I brought before my first real game
hey dude I'm so happy for you man I hate
the jacket brother thank you buddy you
know got this my girlfriend saw um
grandmother picked it nailed it right
how many times is gram 85 year old girl
women
nailed it she's Armenian no she's Jill
okay hey dude I love the Jews dawg
you've been with this one long time I'll
tell ya that's why you couldn't do the
cool [ __ ] you went to a concert with a
one time don't even know you had a
girlfriend you came out 15 years I won
15 but you keep away from the store you
keep a low and raps you know and she's
she's there more than anybody I know
dude really like if you think of all the
guys who've been there forever and their
girls she goes there the most and I'm
cool that she loves comedy I never see
anybody swim in there I know you twenty
years ago met this girl you've met my
girlfriend really yeah Jesus Christ I
stopped smoking reefer you've met her a
bunch of time 15 [ __ ] years
you met her a bunch times I won't know
people at the store for I've been there
since
2099 mm you better [ __ ] you're coming
up on 20 I love it imagine that 20
[ __ ] years I can't believe it
I mean dude it's an I mean that Oh ours
[ __ ] jumping every night right now
every night it's it's and it's amazing
that we saw the upswing like we were
there when nobody was coming there oh
yeah dungeon club like people would look
down I love I'm thankful for those years
me too I learned so much
me too it's The Comedy Store was like
Dangerfield nobody talked about it no
more it existed but it just was
something that it was just polluted it
was too dark for some people but
everything else is on fire the laugh
track in the improv now we saw the whole
[ __ ] thing the whole a man so it's
very interesting to see it's crazy dude
I've been following up Brian Holtzman in
the o.r and I've been killing it I used
to bomb constantly after him he was one
of those guys either he destroys the
room and they're like oh my god it's
great or like he puts him in weird
places he go up now I mean I went up at
11:15 so he did 11 Wow he called me a
few weeks ago with a gate for a gig I
couldn't do the gig I I loved him dude I
and you know man the people come to this
store they're looking for edgy or comedy
so now it's like he's starting to hit
and it's fun to watch he is he's one of
my favorite comedies were favored he's
so different than everybody else and
he's so funny
it was just we had deep deep
conversations I mean I 15 years ago
and he knew that he couldn't do is set
on the road as a feature his set would
not fly right somebody was fired right
Oh
out the gate somebody had liners that
don't like follow that yeah I'll do it
they can't follow us you could get big
again cause I'm gonna be some Long
Island he told me he did a spot one time
that the club owner sizzling governor's
was completely different coming this is
a great club today but 20 years ago was
run by an agency
ah it was a booking agency that ran the
club clean comedy no no no just
was just a [ __ ] they didn't know it
just was something weird so Brian also
went down and it wasn't that it was
clean you know at the time Brian hold he
was talking about letting this kid suck
his dick at a baseball game or some [ __ ]
or something you know I mean they just
wouldn't fly it would fly it it flew at
the Comedy Store because it was late and
and he was comfortable that he's
comfortable there that's not gonna fly
in Detroit that [ __ ] that one club
that's not gonna fly you have to shoot
his special without even knowing it
right that's the thing about him and I
have similar things he we fall apart
when the cameras on like I fall apart
really yeah I don't I mean I did a lot
better like when I did the best thing I
ever did in my opinion was Ahri's things
yeah that's the best but at that time
like I was they wrote specifically on me
and I just blamed myself and I just went
over the top so that in my world is is
good everything else is [ __ ] I think
you're great I mean I've seen your sets
I know you probably beat your [ __ ]
yourself up we do that all the time you
know but I think I love watching your
specials really good I'm super excited
man it's doing really well it's called
zero Fox and I broke it it's two parts
zero [ __ ] and Armageddon and you can
find on vimeo.com backslash on-demand
zero fox or on-demand Armageddon or just
put in sam Tripoli and dude I love it
man
I want when I moved here I'm like I
wanna do my special the Viper Room and
it just happened to work out and the
blessings in my life is that I exactly
produced my own special it's gorgeous
dude and I pretty much made my money
back and I'm about that you know I'm
about to put out the record in February
so I'm super stoked man good for you I'm
so excited and when we moved here the
Viper Room was really hot yeah there was
a line around the
at the Viper Room then Rogen did it one
night and I opened for him there was
[ __ ] tremendous I was back then
they're like right around Fear Factor he
was doing all these auction rooms and I
would open for him in different spots
that's right around what I just got into
the store around that we also did that
room there's a there's a restaurant a
Chinese restaurant or maybe Beverly
Boulevard the mint
yeah cement yes we did the mint it's
like I'm Pico right you go yeah it's
like yeah it's like tea I'd have waited
the mint one night when he was hot we
did the theater on Wilshire when he was
hot this is 2099 did you know Jo when he
wasn't hot I mean like I met Jo when he
was on Newsradio and I didn't know and
he got that like right off the plane
right no no no he had a baseball show
and then that got canceled and then what
kind of a baseball show like a I was on
Fox oh it wasn't like a scripted
baseball really yeah he plays one of the
baseball players or some [ __ ] he got a
deal and he came out here and he shot
the show the show got canceled and then
something happened he got another deal
and they shot this is weird
they shot Newsradio but the original guy
was Rey Romo yeah and he got fired and
Joe replaced him Ray Romano went on to
be seen Ray Romano Romano
so again if Ray Romano would have went
home shut the curtains like Sonny black
and [ __ ] in Donnie Brasco nothing
happens you know what people are the
saying that you and I were talking about
before the show started was like we've
gone through battles like I just
remembered that you apart on Howard
Stern competition and and I remember
just hear you me in front of you I
remember you had a TV show for why they
he did crazy [ __ ] yeah did someone
rampage yeah I fought rampage right you
for writing my own stunts your ID
through year round or something you know
this all this all incorporates your body
of work whether it's negative or
positive you did it you know yeah
it it's just really weird so when Ray
Romano lost that Joe picked up news
radio I move out here and I've become a
regular at the store and that's the
store one night the girl I was with said
oh he's hot
they kept saying Newsradio I never
talked to him I didn't talk to him for
it the first two months there I thought
news radio was a radio show like I was a
comic then you know I'm saying who was
on that Brooke Shields so it was a
tremendous Phil Hartman Phil Hartman one
of the good Andy Dick was Kathy Griffin
on that no no the brunette chick and the
redhead chick that I just saw in the
audition about a year ago she's broke
that she's hooked up with Nick Nolte and
started doing coke Dave whatever it was
a great show let me see just didn't
stand behind it and they kept moving it
around
so welcome Tuesday night the Wednesday
night the Thursday night change like ask
him next time you see him tell me it's
really interesting the show worked and
made it to five years with three
schedule changes hey I've never heard
how you got picked up I always hear
everybody's story about how they ended
up becoming a regular did anything
interesting happen when you got picked
up cuz I've always known you as a
regular that I just saw about that there
is a timing I picked up and we're made a
regular we would I went through the ten
year period the first ten years of my
career and I talked it you know how long
did it take you to get pick up what's it
with a kid right now it's been doing
comedy for a year a little baby a hi
baby
and and people gonna give him [ __ ] about
three months you know he's gonna walk
into a club
somebody's gonna whisper somethin to
somebody's ear and he's gonna see it
he's gonna see that all the things I saw
that you know how people will say oh
well he gets on stage because he said to
Joey is Sam Tripoli I don't believe in
life that way I believe in live in
opportunities right if you got up off
the [ __ ] bed and Boston or flew out
here you're in the game that's your
opportunity if you made a friend
for some reason he puts on his TV show
so be it the guy believed in Yin Rhee
rather you have it in somebody else but
some people can't live with that it
drives him crazy they always gotta say
some well she got it because that's her
father or because whatever whatever was
she went to your [ __ ] audition right
she went to the [ __ ] audition yeah
okay as we could see right now what's
the girlfriend friends Jim Franz yeah
I'll follow whatever look at them she's
a piece of [ __ ] ass yeah yeah and she
could act yeah I'm saying she's still
around twenty years later so obviously
you were [ __ ] wrong
you were [ __ ] wrong you follow me
right well well they got the show
because of the father
no it's called opportunity you got up
off your ass Kristin Lee is like that
he's a super talented guy right now and
you're at the right place at the right
[ __ ] spot yeah that's it so I was
very fortunate
like people have bad luck in their life
it took me a month to get into the store
I got the January 29th and my February
19th I was a regular how could you know
but on the flip side of that Ari
auditioned I'm retired
that guy is either 28 or 38 okay so do
you understand me to rise a man all that
is part of your journey for me I just
happened to log on but I didn't go to
Montreal I never got a big agent I never
had a big manager all those years the
only thing I had was the store so it was
the only thing I had so I had to treat
in a certain way because it was all I
had that was the only person who
believed in me people would come in and
say you're funny but we're not gonna
[ __ ] pick him up he's out of his
[ __ ] mind
we're Mitzi shore promoted my oh yeah
she got that she loved my threw a cue
ball at a car she loved like broke the
microphone she loved the K I love chaos
so I was home you following me so that's
my story it took me three [ __ ] weeks
I want to thank Scott Dano he listens to
the podcast religiously he's in some
[ __ ] country in Bangkok because when
Doug Stanhope it was Doug Stanhope
call of Mencia and somebody else who
vouched me but it's primarily Stanhope
who vow gently when Stanhope vouch for
me how was it staying hopes I was
staying on his bunk beds and the guy
called Stan oh I can't think of his name
I just said his [ __ ] name
Scott Scott they called Stanhope and
said Toby has gonna be six weeks six
weeks to six-month waiting list holy
[ __ ]
do you remember the [ __ ] Laugh
Factory do you have a quarrel a factory
in going IDEs January 7th this is Joey
Diaz like to come on his showcase that
[ __ ] told me October 24th the first
time I called this the Laugh Factory
like I was here like a year and he
commanded no I did a Latino night we
didn't know for sure
I'm a koala like in January and my
showcase was October 24 we used to drive
in from Vegas to do that open mic it was
so good we're at the Laugh Factory used
to driving through the you and Scott
Ross me Scott Ross and I keep Healy and
Mark Hackel used to drive in to do it
where is Joel Lindley where is Mimi
Gonzalez where is Mimi Gonzalez yes
pretty lesbian Cuban half Jewish where
there's so many people I wonder where
they are
I bumped into Mimi dunzo I was gonna try
to [ __ ] track it into Montreal one
time I talked to Bobby slain he knows if
he get to Montreal I'll throw your 5
minutes top spot at the comedy at the
dirty show and I had my money this is
before 9/11 and I mean all the way to
Detroit and I got out of the airport I
go wait a second I'm gonna go to Canada
and walk around like that [ __ ] guy I
hate at the store you know when you have
spots at the store there's always that
one guy that's not a regular yeah well
he lurks he's creepy yeah how was I am I
gonna be their [ __ ] guy I'm not going
to Montreal I'm gonna walk around and
wait for a fire but I guess I can't do
that to my friends
I said [ __ ] it and I just got a room I
told the cab driver take me to the
cheapest room and he took me to the
darkest neighborhood you ever seen your
[ __ ] life in Detroit and I had a rock
the coke rock with me cuz I was coming
from Miami so I have a coke right I
thought in my mind that was the sneaking
into that's how [ __ ] I was tripping
I wasn't sneaking into mantri at all and
I went to Detroit I was gonna try to
take the bus over the border I was like
[ __ ] this and I checked into this
[ __ ] hotel well you got to put a
couch in front of it the door because I
mean that yeah but hey I had 300 bucks
and this was 20 yeah take your own
chances HBO
I was warmed or whatever the [ __ ] it was
it was uh yeah it was warm whatever I'll
never forget that takes his second night
there was a club down the corner called
locos Tom Lee clubs pure black Club
tremendous tremendous I didn't know
Detroit had another black Club called og
all jokes aside in 1995 there was two
black clubs in the country that were
hiring Latinos all jokes aside in
Chicago and all jokes aside in Detroit I
was doing Joey's comedy clown one time
him and Dearborn and like a gavone I
called though jokes aside was featuring
at Joey's I'm like a javo oh the pig
that I am this is why I tell people to
mind their business because I've learned
these lessons right I tell people not to
do this and you do it I'm not telling
you because I'm being a dick I'm telling
you to give this the lesson that's how
you're supposed to experience this is
how your that's what you go through
right i buy could save you the
aggravation right right because I
wouldn't want experiences ever again so
you're at one club getting paid whatever
you're getting paid $50 to set a Finals
is set to feature in those days and
between the shows you know cuz you're a
feature so you you're off stage at 8:30
the other show starts at 8:30 so you
have to get in your car and drive
through and then be back for the 10:30
show defeat oh my god me being a pig
I call all jokes aside didn't know my
way around Detroit you know who knows
nothing right why mine your business
right you know just town now
yeah but the girl forget the [ __ ]
girl forget the girl in the [ __ ] 8
the GPS I ain't go away here's trying
around Detroit so I'm driving on Detroit
downtown Detroit at 7:30 your mind
no no I had to comedy shows I was
straight as an arrow I was showcasing at
all jokes aside so why would you set up
a [ __ ] showcase if you're working at
the other club unless the other Club
doesn't have a Sunday night and your
Sundays open then you get a hotel room
you stay at their condo and you showcase
that's what you do I went against
protocol I got the showcase on the
Saturday night show I already ate a bag
of dicks of joeys so here I am driving
on the treadle nothing like I finally
get there 22 Park you know
yeah there's you another drive around
for two hours right you got a shirt on
kiddin get out you're showcasing you
gotta look good so I had like valet the
[ __ ] car running and it was like
seventies night it was like a black
seventies retro name-o everybody was
dynamite everybody was cool more you
know like the nice jackets people
dancing they're like let's get this
comedy club started and the whole thing
that they had the deejay and I mean it
was a great little club and I don't know
who I worked with
I don't can't even tell you all I know
is going up there and just made a
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of your bond which I
bombed in the Arab on my back okay so
take it take a [ __ ] terrorist put a
bomb on them and then put them on my
shoulders that's how bad I [ __ ] bombed
because I was all [ __ ]
yeah cuz you're just running in you
didn't get chances of that income poll
you don't think about everybody wanted
to talk to you yeah yeah yeah it was
only then no no I was still in Colorado
I wasn't even in seattle yet that's how
green that was that's how [ __ ] green I
was I wasn't even featuring yet hoping
the prayer that's all you had but I ran
over there ate a bag of dicks and I'm
number walking out of there nobody would
make I fell worst and you know he's
knowing you know don't do well the black
Club
get paint no there was not doing gonna
pay me they just stopped talking to me
if I have a good set boom I get paid if
I don't have a good set Donal it was the
show how much there was no money
involved at all this is me coming down
on a feature act
I like the showcase because you know you
have two clubs yeah come on by brother
you know okay I figured I'd go down
there do 20 and a book yeah that's two
weeks of work who cares if it's a black
Club I didn't give a [ __ ] I'm just
looking to [ __ ] I was running I was
running so I went in there just ate a
bag of dicks I don't even go up to the
guys and I'll call you Monday
yeah can't be that stupid I drove back
to Joey's and then another bag of dicks
that was the end of that night
oh so many bags of dicks but now that's
why you're a monster dude well that's
what people do not understand that
drives me crazy people think now and
Stan know how you do stand-up before
years
you just stand at home what are you
crazy all I need is a podcast and I can
make it no you don't know you know
because you're doing all the wrong
things for the wrong [ __ ] reasons I
think you just miss out on the fun too
like I mean the learning of all these
all this stuff I know in comedy now was
I wouldn't trade it for anything nothing
no the knowledge I've learned this is on
you have to do it because if not this
will come back to bite you in the ass
later dude when I fouled Brian Holtzman
the other night I was like wow dude I
I've gotten good like that was assigned
to me that I've done something because
I've watched that guy in niall eight
rooms and bury people and I used to get
so scared there's a couple people that I
know if I'm following
I gotta gear up you're one of them you
and what is their name Lisa Lampanelli
are the two worse bombs I've ever had
we're following you and Lisa Lampanelli
at one time to the point where I went in
my car and I said what am I doing with
my life why am I doing this and so I
learned from all these things you know
and it's just like to be able to file
Brian Holtzman the other night was just
two nights in a row and do really well I
was like wow that's growth dude and that
I had to go through so much to get to
that moment I've had the bad
two dicks forever because what's you
know edgy comedies didn't even though we
got political correctness now edgy
comedies in now when I started it wasn't
people want to be like Seinfeld and I
knew I wasn't Seinfeld I did do my own
thing which was like raw and real way I
was in Vegas you know I'll tell you
that's one thing I love about that scene
is that they're really wrong they're
real that's political correctness isn't
doing very well and they in the Vegas
economy scene as far as I could tell
so I mean I learned the hard way I
didn't play really play I played a
comedy club one week before I went to
Montreal and I bombed there because I
just I'd tapped into something in my
showcase and I I tapped in the showcase
that I understand and I own now but I
didn't know then and then they put me
following court hokum at that time was a
20 year veteran I mean that guy's been
doing comedy I think he opened for Jesus
Christ Corey Holcomb he's been doing it
that long and he's a killer now I could
follow him no problem but back then
baguette did what I remember something
for the people listening we all bomb in
life every day because bombing basically
is 70 percent mental bombing is 70 to 80
percent mental and I just learned this
five years ago how long have I been back
at the store yeah like four or five
years now or five years I've learned
this so this didn't come to me at the
twenty mr bombing is like anything else
in your life that you'd overall you lost
in your mind before you showed up
how do I know cuz I was the king of
bombing bombing well you asked an
interesting question before the time I
had met okay so Joe's at the store and
one day during crossing he said
something to me and I said something
back and we shook hands and I Lou him is
Joe and he would talk call me Joe and
then one day he was we were both on the
405 how weird is that there used to be a
club in Orange County that on Wednesday
nights it would get
400 people was a dinner theater when I
first got here and they pay you 200
bucks on it but it was rough I was white
people Orange County with white Hill
rough still roughing it was a dinner
theater so they way they get salmon
mashed potatoes or whatever the [ __ ]
that was and you had to go up then they
only like the headliner to emcee in the
feature always bombed I'll never forget
being in bumper-to-bumper traffic and
looking over to my left and it was Joe
Rogan he had a super at the time and he
opens up his window and he goes way you
had it like a la Orange County do a
[ __ ] gig whatever some plants [ __ ]
you're not gonna get the storm I like an
eye because you work another place they
go yeah and it was like wow like he
didn't really understand and then one
that I'm at the store on a Friday night
and I'm bobbing I'm dying a slow death
at that time I was going through a
control issue I want to learn how to
control the audience this is all that
stupid white [ __ ] you bump into out here
and your mind was just - stand up - shut
your [ __ ] mouth
I don't think just shut your mouth this
was the time in my life when I got into
you have to take long pause pauses to
control them and I went up there on a
Friday and I have the store dog and I
bombed and beginning it was just a long
bomb and I'll never forget at the end
11-minute mark I said to myself oh this
is killing me and Joe Rogan yelled
you're killing me
and I knew is his voice distinctly and I
didn't know how to react to it like when
I get offstage do I say something to
this guy while I go you know what he
ain't lyin but he ain't mine
I'm dying appeared I'm [ __ ] this is a
nightmare and I walked off and I saw
what we lay there and I was I've thrown
like a man that may you said that you're
right you know I was [ __ ] it was
probably that was brutal something and
after that I said to him what show are
you on and he told me and he was like so
courteous he goes if you want come watch
a taping really knows day
I used to go to our hobbies were to go
to politically incorrect when I taped on
wilshire me stay on Oh Mitch Hedberg we
don't go down there I was launched of us
in those days they used to tape
politically incorrect like to turn in
the afternoon so if you weren't doing
anything KP anderson was the warm-up so
you could call KP Wow
I'm coming now put me out a list you go
into the audience and then they would
send you around a sheet of paper comics
or people you want to see I'm
politically incorrect and we knew that
Gilmore hated Stan oh oh why we would
all put Stanhope on then send to them
and [ __ ] this is just something you did
to learn like this is how cool it was
then yeah you wanna go see it's a show
taping to learn like you have to go to a
show taping and I went to lose radio and
the first time I sat in the audience and
Joe came over like a gentleman
he's lose everything okay and I go yeah
and he goes have Captain creepy bothers
you let me know captain creepy was the
[ __ ] warm-up guy and then Joe's mind
Joe didn't smoke pot then but in Joe's
mind the guy was a rapist so Joe would
actually [ __ ] say it like when I
first met Joe he did not smoke pot I
remember it was he was by the book he
was anti pop right at that pot he was by
the [ __ ] book and I'll never forget
him coming up to me and he had no
manners like he was very [ __ ] like he
would tell I he's Boston Riley very
blunt and I've never forgiven he came up
and he goes are you having a good time
yeah I got and I went to one of the show
taped his but he came up and he goes the
guy was with Lee is and he goes don't
let Captain creepy [ __ ] with you and
then black man I go what do you call
captain creepy and he goes that guy's
definitely they rape people and if you
looked at this guy he looked like a date
rape like you didn't want a judge but
when he looked at the guy he like this
guy rapes odd he was so creepy
like this guy was a professional warm of
God that was just like out there like
you knew you know when he would flirt
with women and he was trying to get him
up
like and he would disappear with some of
them ourselves they were and you had an
edict on the set
oh my god so handy dick would come up to
you and talk to you so the [ __ ] then I
became friends with him and he would
invite me to the show and they would put
me on the floor and I'll never forget it
they had a thing for people and they had
a box for NBC and they had shrimp
cocktails prawns the size of my [ __ ]
gorilla hand I love the house on the
side of a thing like two hundred shrimp
and I walked in there and I just thought
eating shrimp and finally somebody went
up to Joe and said who's that scary guy
and the NBC rule means shrimp Joe came
on they're like oh my god you're scaring
everybody here with your leather jacket
cuz I had this big gorilla leather
jacket oh oh but that's how we became
friends from that awesome from that
thing and then I was working Miami and
he how'd you do in Miami at that time I
used to do great and he called me and he
goes where are you and I'm in Miami just
[ __ ] I'll be there next week I go I
could stay and I stayed in the Christmas
wide-open front at the time I just
exchanged calls of Chrystia Chris has
wonderful this is wonderful and I stayed
MC true and that's how I got to meet him
more more more and then over the years
you know at the store you just built
these store bonds that you see you you
know the bond of a comic when when we
really love each other
I just didn't want her strong it's a
gang like I got into this to be in a
gang and I've never wanted to be in a
gang
ha you know I got into this to being
again I was very disappointed with the
Joe Rogan thing what I think went down
the town restore and the people in back
that's when I started losing faith in
comics I didn't like that that turned me
off about Thomas I don't feel that way
anymore it's a long time ago but I
didn't like that situation because it
felt like embouchure for themselves so I
made the wrong call on that one right
that was a bad move we get a lot of bad
wolves and uh you know I'm happy that
he's back there I'm
oh it's against the place I didn't I
didn't get thrown out I walked out of
there my own accord
I just knew that the governor was
changing I knew that I had already I had
been there for six years
no 97 it was 2007 I'd been there for 10
years if this was Michigan I would be
out if this was illinois' I would be out
if this was Boston the end of club owner
would go Joey you gotta do something
you're featuring you know just nowhere
to go working you how much farther can
you go so that's I left the store before
Joe methanol now I saw the writing on
the wall I saw that [ __ ] coming in
with his new attitude there's the regime
and I was hearing little things and I
said you don't want I'm the type of guy
huh I'll end up getting into a fight
down and hit him on the head or
something wrong I'm going in jail I'm
just gonna stop all dammit
there was a dark time I'm very thankful
for it there but it was a dark time and
I'm glad that Joe went back and that has
been the resurgence of that place and
now it's just this cooking with gas yeah
you know I look at you and I look at Joe
and I look it I look at a lot of people
sometimes you have to leave the store
you have to leave one of the most
important things in life is making sure
nobody ashes later I don't ever want to
be in a situation since I was a kid I
always knew what I had a wall kind of
girl I always knew my mother was gonna
talk business I always knowing men were
talking business
I was never said excuse us I don't ever
want you to tell me excuse me I should
pick it up by the body language and
what's called on the [ __ ] rule and
the same applies to life you have to
know when it's time to walk away yeah
and stick to your guns and walk away and
take your chances and go that's it I'm
not doing this anymore I'm gonna become
a comic and for a year I'm gonna eat
[ __ ] I'm gonna drink ramen and live in
my car but this is what's gonna happen
I can't that's the transition between
quit need a job which I'm gonna comment
the first year is
hardest part you ever have in your life
it's the hardest thing you'll ever do in
your life right saying I'm not doing
that no more yeah
cut me umbilical cord is scary it's like
you've got a real scary thought one day
I'm looking at somebody and going I'm
not doing this no more bro I'm doing
comedy and for 90 days you make 300 a
month
you better have no savings and then the
next 90 days you make five hun yeah
three months then you start making eight
hundred nine you keep steady at that did
you get two weeks of work a month for
5500 you know as a feature
ya know plane ticket you know no plane
ticket this is 500 and the plane tickets
to 30 in those days you're clearing 270
yeah but you do what you love you're in
a hotel room you're eating you're doing
drugs you're getting your dick sucked it
was a great time not working I loved it
Oh
once you decide that's the scariest all
these moves the decision-making moves
but back to bombing bombing as a gaming
Mohammed is like that that feel cold
tonight that you saw unbelievable he
missed the first thing do you not miss
the first one I didn't he he had a game
wearing it four times he hit the
crossbar yeah like he hit the crossbar
tonight if he hit it four times it's
stuck in his mind
unbelievable stuck in your money you
know like when you see a and I think
that's what happened they went to kick
and they call the timeout
whenever you see a team call a time on
it's to make you think you have two free
throws and you see a timeout being
called it's to make you think it's to
make you walk away to make you think
about what you're gonna do to give you
time to realize what you're doing we do
our best work when you're unconscious
you know I'm saying why if I you know I
used to I used to work for a sports
betting service and I noticed that my
best day is with Saturday's the restful
week I'd be sitting there like this she
drew you know all my best days the
Sabbath does I do my last line at 6:00
in the morning so I was going in there
working off basics choji's you live the
most interesting [ __ ] life when you
work off basics you do perfect it's like
jujitsu
why am I gonna struggle with you if I
know if I hold that thing right there
specific time you're gonna go whether
your 300-pound a dirty pallet
you're gonna go cause it's technique
sometimes you ever get [ __ ] high and
go on stage you you get stoned till he
kills me on stage part of the [ __ ]
reason you do good is craziest no oh
yeah
part of the reason you do well it's cuz
you're high cuz you're not thinking
about it it's when you think about what
you're about to do that things go bad
yeah when you overanalyze and you get to
the store
I don't even when they call you and they
say grab a pen
Tuesday 11:30 Wednesday 12:45
I don't even ask who's in front of me I
don't want to know and I don't need to
know it don't matter but it's my channel
yeah I made a decision but it's my
channel it doesn't matter now I'll
follow anybody it's a decision I feel
now it's a switch in your head it's a
switch a jet and it takes you used to
switch it it takes you you lie to
yourself and go like this year since six
years to switch it it takes years to
follow Whitney Cummings
and get the stink of Whitney Cummings
off the statement that she's thinking
the the aroma it's right the fellow Jody
isn't right right you learn how to
follow up all Moody and get it right off
the stage right cuz there's no host
people don't realize everyone's not a
host which brings us on it up and if
someone crushes they do a little time so
you forget about what just happened so
the new guy gets a new didn't clean
slate you know or if the guy bombed the
host goes up there tries to get the ball
rolling a little bit more not The Comedy
Store if someone just flamed throughout
the room you have to follow that Frick
Ingram in the main room just crushed you
have to go in there and and just like
figure it out but if you're sitting
there the last three minutes while he's
crushing and you're thinking about it
you're gonna die yeah for sure he'll die
I'm dead on the inside not going sighs
and say let's keep it all for tram
Tripoli didn't he'd do great Jesus
Christ yeah you're done just go up there
[ __ ] stamp trip and Sam Tripoli destroys
the room don't even mention Sam's name
just gonna keep it going one more time
and stop at that don't even say sands
name
keep it going one time and right through
there you gotta unleash your right
[ __ ] bomb a right overhead [ __ ]
bomb and another one and another one and
another one and then now you settled
them and they got the composure like
this [ __ ] yeah ain't [ __ ]
yeah and now that's it he went on and if
the first one doesn't hit don't panic it
second one done right don't don't just
stay in the pocket in the pocket
say hey I see young calm open up your
life tighten up your leg like you're
about to throw a [ __ ] bomb and let
high always say that once I get in the
pocket you're finished the store is all
about being in the moment that is the
biggest thing it is like it's not a
monologue okay
it's what is going on right now and that
is what makes that room so insane and
that's why Comedy Store comics are like
no other because it's just like there is
a voodoo in that or that it takes a long
time to master
and once you do you can pretty much go
anywhere and just do really well you
know it's just like get out be in the
moment be in the moment don't overthink
okay and just believe in yourself right
and that's for me is what has really
made me a great comic from that or is
that I'm so in the moment I'm not you
know I don't care what the guy did
before me okay I'm gonna do me and I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna stick to my
guns and I know I have a million tricks
that I can throw out there to sell this
whole thing and it's just the blessing
of doing it over time you know yeah what
I love too made it earlier or if I've
even made it at all but it love to made
it earlier yeah but you know what things
worked out the way they worked out they
worked out and you have to accelerate
where I need to be keep swinging [ __ ]
dick this is what you're saying does not
apply just to stand them it applies to
life these things you're saying the
basics of life yeah you know and I don't
want people to think wow well they just
a little too cocky so no no no I'm
trying to lay ting what the languages of
Konami - life for you guys see you guys
understand what that you're going
through the same thing in your job
I failed so much early that I don't take
a personal anymore
no and it's just like it's on to the
next one I don't celebrate the big
things too much you know because that
too shall pass just look and I don't
take personal to fails dude it's on to
the next one what is the next project
what is the next am working on bah bah
bah I don't worry about it and I just
celebrate whatever little things I have
cuz those are the beautiful things man
if you know you want to be Vince Vaughn
or you want to be you'll drive yourself
crazy trying to do that but feel like
I'm gonna be the bad man dude I flunked
first grade homeboy my parents were
looking for [ __ ] receipts for store
credit on me you know I was like out the
gate I failed and I just was like I
remember going I'm not gonna let this
stop me and I just kept working work and
work and working you know I got I've I
was fired from like 15 day jobs
I couldn't keep a day job good because
all I wanted to do is be a comic bang
all I want even before I knew what a
comic was that's what I wanted to be I
just wanted to be it and I was
determined to do whatever I could and
the things I learned early like
promoting dude be like I I was in Vegas
when there weren't there wasn't there's
one open mic every other week they
wouldn't hire us to do shows at the cut
at the comedy clubs there we had to make
our own time and for like 24 years 20 21
years now I've been basically producing
shelves and like now with the show at
the comedy juice of amina comedy chaos
at the Comedy Store is just doing great
and that's like a long a long journey to
learn how to do that and to learn like
to make money with my with people
instead of off people and treat people
like gold man you know like those are
things that I had to learn over time and
this quick fix thing that everybody
wants it's gonna hurt you in the long
run because you're not gonna make the
mistakes when nobody is looking that's
the beauty of it when we're at the
Comedy Store and there's 12 people in
the O our and no industries there what a
blessing that is to be able to bomb
freely you know and now the thing is
just fire
you know it's so crazy that this place
that was just basically my coke and sex
den is now like the mecca of comedy it's
always been but it's like really is now
you know so it's sex then I love it I
love it no I agree with listen man I get
so drunk I walked 300 people in the main
room at The Comedy Store what did you
say I just was I mean I came out wasted
wait I
Tiffany Haddish that [ __ ] you know I
went I was wasted and the entire room
just got up and left and she banned me
for two days
what's he there oh yeah oh yeah oh she
was amazing the first spot I ever got
there I felt Charles Fleischer and I
died I mean I died and I thought well
I'm done there and yeah I got called
next day from Duncan she wants you to go
up again and that's what I knew that
place was different it was like you
could fail there and I I don't think
people appreciate a good fail and how
important it is you know it's so it's
the blessings I tell people more knows
you get you closer to it yes yeah the
more nose you get you closer to yeah
well when somebody says no cuz I'm one
day away from one of the Academy Award
it's just a [ __ ] nod
you know boy every time you hear another
I don't want you okay
nah they don't think you're right for it
okay I'm only thinking too fast they
think you're too dirty
first of all I gotta disagree one thing
with you it's always this town has
always tried to be a little PC side and
that's where I failed in this town early
on that I didn't join to those rules and
I wouldn't I wouldn't
I still remember people coming to me and
we really want you for this you need
seven minutes clean and I just I don't
know off the bat I didn't even try
there's times today I feel bad about
that I should've tried you know they
always want
before that stupid [ __ ] show at night
what's the one that comes with NBC at
night Saturn I live late late night
every night it comes on the black dude
didn't he ask questions even after
[ __ ] the music guy they may ask
questions and they always lead you into
the Atomics I love comics only so many
[ __ ] times they came to see me at the
store and then we go we need to clean
Seth
they really want you like I knew early
on that wasn't gonna be on Letterman
Leno or Conan look like I made that
decision and even though Sinbad always
said to work clean because you could
work universally and all that I
appreciate that I do too but I'm from
the disciple it's not me
I do not have any interest in working
clean I do not want to work clean and
the [ __ ] that comes out of my mouth Lee
knows it comes into my model irregular
yeah it flows like water you Mets me too
dude Anna to Wyatt yeah that's who you
have to and it's really hard to figure
that out you have to challenge yourself
against that do I change my set I saw
20,000 people change this set and you
know what all right Pete yep because
they all wanted to be signed so all they
want be this guy the whole notion that
if you tried to work like Seinfeld you
could have the success of Seinfeld is
ridiculous Seinfeld is where he is just
like Sebastian Maniscalco is where he is
because that is who they are that is
really them that and that's why they
shine because they're authentic to that
if I did that I would not be authentic
to me and I am where I am and I'm doing
what I'm doing but dude I wouldn't be
selling out for four nights of the at
Madison Square Garden if I decide to
work like Sebastian Maniscalco it works
for him because that is him you have to
do you you know when you showcase in
this town man people just you know you
always like Oh were they looking for
they don't know what they're looking for
go up there and do your favorite [ __ ]
because that's all you can have it'll
ruin that's all you can control I've
seen people bomb and get it I've seen
people
and get told no it doesn't matter just
on to the next one do what makes you
happy cuz at the end of the day is the
only thing you can control and that's
just in life back to last week does this
was hysterical I wake up one day last
week and you've gone off on Judd Apatow
that's not what this conversation is
about the conversation is about louis
c.k I'm gonna get this out there just he
got me a job one time have I ever eaten
lunch louis c.k no I've ever hung out
with him no I don't know him and that
personal level I worked when he was a
head writer on set at the entertainer's
sketch show on Fox 15 years ago and I
put him up at the store Sunday night he
goes I got a role for you in a few days
I'm coy and he called and I was
respectful because of that the next you
know he's one of the biggest [ __ ]
comics in the world and all these kids
are telling you about Louie Louie Louie
six years ago and all of a sudden you
find out that in Montreal in 2001 he
took his dick out or in 2003 I don't
know a year was and now it's just his
big thing somebody did ten years earlier
and now it comes out I know that he
jerked off on the phone he did all this
crazy stuff whatever whatever whatever
okay how long does it take before we
forgive what kills me is that the same
people that put him up there are the
same people that took him down you can't
get recho you can't get haha you can't
get a [ __ ] offended retro actively
you can't you guys literally be like I
don't know leave ck from anybody you
know he's never done anything for me and
I am not that that means anything so I
I've no I've nobody the right of the
station women for like a brief second
you know like I try to run like famous
cons go up I do I try to give them their
space at the store you know I don't
really try to go up well it's going I
like you know I'm sure they're just in
their head I've never done anything for
me but I used to watch Lucy kay and I'm
like man
he is allowed to say some amazing things
and he was great at it I'm not taking
anything away great at it these people
that allowed him to say all this stuff
are now the ones acting like it is the
end of the [ __ ] world thank you okay
I thought I was doing one that felt that
way all these people are calling him out
are all were dying to work with him and
my biggest problem at Judd Apatow and I
know this isn't it it's just like why
don't you go talk to a man like why do
you got a blast this guy I'm [ __ ]
Twitter man you're like you used to work
with this dude I mean like they all
worked with this dude they all wanted to
be in the louis c.k business and he got
he got pulled into this me to [ __ ] with
some very dark [ __ ] which i
don't think he falls under know he may
be sexually deviant Who am I to judge
I'm a sexual deviant okay but you all
want to work with him and if you don't
think he's paying a price right now dude
he dude he was the king and now he can't
go anywhere and nobody's shown and
they're all being disrespectful because
it's all this virtual signaling going on
and it's like all this [ __ ] for what
happened last week let's go to the
starters he was at governor's and
somebody taped the set yeah and they
released his satin which he did some
jokes about the Parkland shootings and
the transgender people and people went
nuts and and first of all they recorded
and put it out they should not do that
that's not cool
and everybody gonna not sign him about
hey it's not funny to do this well dude
he's not presenting it yet it is a work
in progress he's not putting it on a
special right now
this is him working out bits and you
know at the end of the day dude the
crowd decides what's funny and what's
not funny and they were all laughing
yeah they were a laughing man they loved
it it's funny
it's classic those guy taped it instead
of the TMZ yeah that's how this whole
thing store
yeah and then you know and then all
everybody comes out and they start Lam
blasting him it's like dude if you don't
think he's paid a price you don't think
there's a punishment people like you
should be in jail
he's never what a charge me for Louie I
don't know what do you think is it I
mean what is the punishment for Louie
who the [ __ ] are we to decide yeah
anybody's punishment you know he would
live in glass houses cast the first
[ __ ] stone I know I've done some
[ __ ] sick [ __ ] you know whatever it
might not be in a sexual deviant way but
you know how long do we push these
people away this thing that happened
with Louie happened when in 2003 yeah
2003 and it blew up when in 2016
yep 13 years later you know I don't know
and then other people came out against
Lou yeah you know I mean you could look
at a lot of P it's not you soluti chris
hardwick the same thing happened I mean
like this guy gave so many people that
their first credits on @midnight
and when this chick came out with this
core ship stuff about him being a she
would they mean say did anything you
just she just said he was a bad
boyfriend and dude this town crucified
him but not even lose [ __ ] no they I'm
gonna bring it back but why does he got
go through that it just say just it's
about heads on stakes and people trying
to they just see some people trying to
use it to get PR for themselves and
that's gonna piss some people off saying
you but it won't believe this
you know there's some people like who
like gave interviews about [ __ ] about
this whole me to stuff they were fully
involved in trying to get that career
going now am i saying that men in this
town aren't animals no 100% said okay
I've seen it I've seen it I've seen it
with I witnessed men doing [ __ ] crazy
things we've seen listen man not to harp
on it we've seen a lot of crazy
yeah I feel as economic I've seen things
that are [ __ ] repulsive I've seen
woman women in different cities do
things a repulsive I've heard of things
this is the comedy game people come out
here and they don't know they do not
know and it's just like there's [ __ ]
sharks in these waters and it's the last
people you'd expect you know there's
sharks me what about that girl from the
store the one that was shaved she shaved
Doug Stanhope with balls on stage in
Austin in 98 oh that's why Doug Stanhope
was banned from Austin because he shaved
the balls up last there was that and the
girl moved to San Diego great girl I
love to the death real cute and her
roommate was a gay guy that worked at
the Laura comedy store
oh um but this girl was a she grew up in
a circus a father
yes yes yes yeah the circus yes so she
knew some magic or something she was not
only a comic but she wasn't me I used to
go I used to work with her in Vegas she
used to be a comic out in Vegas and then
she came up here to do a magic show for
a pilot for NBC like how like a like
some type of entertainment in seven I
gotta say 15 years ago her and I were
friends and she was cute and she was
young and then she went to New York for
a while and she started hanging that
sounds calmly hall when Sal's comedy
Hall got hot and she was like a door
girl at South she would call me and say
if he ever knew you're gonna get your
spotted Sal's then she came back here
and she started working a magic and
she'd gotten to the aim date and they
put her in a hotel the magic Hotel Magic
Castle Magic Castle and one of the guys
raped her and she had a press charges
leaving away and she has a shame the
meaning of dying and married Idahoan the
gay guy from the store it's still her
room and I know he was in the Houston
fifteen years later I mean there's been
barracudas in this town this is a
discovery there are monsters first sure
you're a woman and you have to know you
have to know you cannot beat that that
naive
this is a pisses me off this is what
makes me talk to my daughter every
[ __ ] day today we'll walk him back to
the partner she's [ __ ] around
Oh yo he's gonna turn six in two days
you gotta knock this [ __ ] off when you
walk the streets I need you paying
attention mercy and she was doing like
what are you talking my god she's not
like that Bush somebody gonna be [ __ ]
behind that Bush they don't understand
you know right right right right I show
an articles to [ __ ] like that so she
sees guns and she like that's us you
don't get it fine cuz in her world she's
a kid you know she's not from my world
I'm not man enough for that but you have
to [ __ ] know where these people are
coming from nobody in this town is that
[ __ ] nice I was just talking to a
girl at the store like Christmas she
said that she came out here two years
ago then she was a club but again and
she didn't have a place to live and I
offered her a house
the guest house and she could live there
for free and he goes to have the two
nights the guy would go out there and
make it and knock on the door what'd you
expect would you expect Frank people
ride nice no rent right he goes put the
guy's wife lived right inside that's
what you dealing with yeah that's the
animal if you're dealing with yeah she
said that she couldn't believe that he
could see you could see the wife sitting
in the living room watching TV and he'd
be out there with his robe like like up
like showing him like like his and she
would say can you please close the room
come on just let me in I'm giving you
free rent she said yeah and this way she
had a move cry
nobody rides for free didn't it nobody
rides for free in this you know and I'll
assess grass a house nobody rides are
free in this property it's easy it's
hard on women for sure it's hard on
everybody boo it's hard on everybody
they killed now on the road dick yeah
yeah they dicta
to death yeah they ran trains honor they
were in train so they were passing a
very deep inner before that was the same
messages that Kennedy's DiMaggio Sinatra
she was the Kennedy bike everybody's
riding her it was and you know over the
years you've seen it you you know you've
seen it you've heard a little things you
were your things
yeah and you you know how they were
gonna wanna hear I don't repeat them I
hear I'll repeat them but I hear them
you know the comi store is a very dark
and sexual [ __ ] harvey esque type of
place for a while everybody knows that
you know but wait what quit yeah I just
love that you I read what you said to
him and I have nothing against I listen
man I have nothing against Judd Apatow I
don't like when people I'm just gonna
say this and this is me talking I don't
like when people use public forums to
shame their own Judd Apatow a long time
ago went onstage at a award show and he
destroyed Jerry Lewis just destroyed him
Jerry Lewis and may come and say didn't
think women were funny Jerry Lewis at
the time I think was well into his 80s
if not 90s but pretty sure 80s and Judd
Apatow on stage and [ __ ] lit him up
about being a male chauvinist pig and
how you should respect female comedy and
I thought ma'am why would you do that to
a [ __ ] legend and then like a week
two weeks later girls comes out and you
know I just don't think that's what
comics should do to comics and I don't
have anything against showed Apatow but
I just don't like that man you used to
run with this guy dude you play the club
he plays go talk to a man say something
to him he like dude you're jut [ __ ]
Apatow you're an 800-pound gorilla dude
you can show up to any comedy show and
go up whenever the [ __ ] you want you
knew this guy man go up
say something dude be like hey man
listen I know I've been [ __ ] going
off on you into I want police I listen
dude
you got a dress that's the big thing
everybody wants him to address it but
they don't or say that this is a process
he isn't presenting it yet and maybe
he's just trying to get the confidence
to talk about to get back to where he
was well you wrote right that he was a
hack with what he's talking about
wouldn't give a [ __ ] how kill it and I
get what you saying there's a lot of
comic beats I get what you saying he was
doing out of Hollywood measure yeah
virtual sitting virtue signaling if
that's what's called yeah you know and
it's kind of weird in a way to do but
I'm not mad at Louie you know I'm upset
because he was a talented guy and yeah I
don't know I just don't like that all of
a sudden we have this power to judge how
long we could hold somebody down you do
something wrong
press lots of charges and go to jail you
know what I did something wrong I did my
time like a man I said I ran to
Nicaragua and ran a Hertz car rental
place I was a Hertz trainee I could have
done a thousand things at the end of a
little more like oh you know what I'm
gonna pay my debt because this is my
debt for all the other things I did now
I'll be comically saved I did my [ __ ]
time and I did my time if you want to
call me a [ __ ] kidnap or I robbed
somebody or a thief be my guest
it doesn't hurt my feelings I did my
time and I walked out there a [ __ ]
man I really did I walked out of the
room and it was that last push to become
a man I understood my position in the
world now I understood what I had to do
to get somewhere did I have the balls to
even make that jump I was you know
20-something [ __ ] years old when I
got out 28 years old did I have the
balls it took me two years to get on
stage two years you won't talk about
procrastination being a fan fear fear is
a [ __ ] here dude but if you
didn't press nobody press try
louis c.k formal charges in front of a
judge or whatever then it's up to
society or louis c.k to make this right
I've had this discussion on it before
then how long does a person have to pay
to society but I don't know you dick Sam
yeah and you don't know me dick I
believe in second chance and I believe
in sure there was that second third
fourth and fifth chances man the best
way to see if he's learned a lesson it's
the you know there's no saying give
person enough rope that they'll hang
themselves right some way I love it let
him see what he done let's see if he's a
DA if he's changed man now I'm gonna
tell you something the the people not
calling him out are are Julia and and
Dana the two girls that happen to they
haven't done any of this they haven't
gone after him they did that article
they left out a lot of information that
they had said that because it didn't fit
the narrative that everybody wanted okay
Dana and Julia had a wonderful career
where are they uh they're just they they
they had an animation on TV they sell
scripts they're wonderful people there
too super funny people they didn't ask
for this they didn't cause this they
didn't want that they told me this story
like ten years before it blew up and all
these people man
they're coma I'm like I don't want to
get names cuz it's your show but they're
people made hundreds of thousands of
dollars off Lucy Kay right now that are
[ __ ] annihilating him you knew what he
was you knew who he was and you took the
cash and prizes you knew who he was so
how do I know that cuz I knew he was and
I was just a late-night dick Joe comic
at the Comedy Store
okay you knew who he was what he's doing
and you took the cash and prizes
you can't retroactively Lee [ __ ] and be
like oh he's a bad guy you knew who
there are people who have careers right
now because of Lewis CK all right now
this whole thing that they're trying to
lump them in with Bill Cosby and would
[ __ ] Weinstein he's not that listen
he jerked off in front these girls now
he asked for permission from what I
understand and people can come he asked
for permission right there he is not
Bill Cosby okay
now people want to keep saying he rape
people he didn't rape people he jerked
off and from people that's not rape man
and how do I know that because it
happened to me did I was at the and when
I went to college 91 at UNLV was at the
book at the library went upstairs went
down this one aisle this huge black guy
just [ __ ] slow stroke and it did now
it's like holy [ __ ] and I walked and I
ran back to my hotel I will tell you
today I did not get raped okay it was
[ __ ] creepy it wasn't fun to go
through really [ __ ] sucked
okay so we're trying to put him in with
these [ __ ] people that that's not him
now he's shutting door everybody's
bringing it's just some weird [ __ ]
[ __ ] everybody wanted a [ __ ] head on
a stake that's what that me to movement
and now it's gone where's the me to
movement where is that oh well because
everybody the left was getting taken out
that's why I [ __ ] stopped they were
taking out their own [ __ ] people
where's the me to movement the aw dude
guys just learn to be respectful no I
know it's hard to be a female cop
there's also a lot of [ __ ] perks to
being a female comic there's less of you
okay
social media if you're attractive you
get more likes more followers all that
[ __ ] right then that helps forgetting
book down the road that helps in this
day and age getting agents there are
perks comedies [ __ ] hard man it's
hard for everybody some people think
they just don't walk right to their
dreams it's because they're being held
back by go it's not like that man
it's a hard business if it was easy
everybody would be doing it and now it
seems like everybody is doing stand-up
you know but it's it's just like dude I
don't know what this guy has to do to
[ __ ] be given a second chance
you know he helped a lot of people and I
know he was a sexual deviant you know
yeah
we're not no comics comedy is how much
money you make off your mental illness
okay that's what it is the more mentally
ill the better the comic you are he
deserves a second chance
and if you don't think having everything
stolen taken away from you not so taken
away from you
the way he has we went from the king of
the hill to public enemy number one
it's [ __ ] a punishment and at least
two girls will never call the cops never
sued or anything like that
there's been no she I didn't know all
this stuff little by little it's like I
knew but I didn't want to know they did
bad birds bashing it listen he how long
was the Cosby Show on horn let's take
that for example they all knew that too
a lot of heat and a lot of [ __ ] a couple
weeks ago for saying something on the
road about this but I'm not lying to you
it's it's the truth I know eight years
for that one and then there was another
one after it wasn't there for eight
years you know all these rapes a lot of
the rapes they talk about the trailers
they want the trailer he raped them Lee
you're no [ __ ] criminal you're a nice
guy you got jury duty tomorrow do you
think that somebody was at NBC for eight
years and all those women that complain
that they got raped in a [ __ ] trailer
you think NBC ever got a win to this
what do you think all those years just
just stop that but chick getting raped
in the trailer waking up cause I think
they knew issue well didn't come out
like that people were bringing of
bringing people to hammer if it wasn't
him maybe was Weinstein the story's kind
of getting mixed up one agents bringing
people Tim Weinstein
I think Weinstein yeah
I'm just focused on MBC I mean you don't
think MBC no it's the biggest show on TV
the biggest show on TV this guy you know
I have to look into this before I could
talk about the time I'll have the time
to look into how many chicks he raped on
the set one said they got abused by him
on the set I know there was a lot of
[ __ ] women guys there was a lot of
women involved in the Cosby case and
where there's smoke there's definitely
for sure dude right now
they threw Cosby in jail now let's talk
about Harvey waters say one thing all we
want to sing that his deep pockets like
I said on the road and podcasts and a
lot of people upset with me he's got
Benjamin Bradley
Benjamin Bradley is a [ __ ] savage but
guess what when they saw a child they
that all changes when they want set a
trial date that all changes he fires
Benjamin Bradley
oh no he won't fire bunion graft they'd
be stupid to fire Brendan Bradley
he just had to woman to counsel he's
feeling in the minority and a white
Barracuda I'd like to say she could be
Jewish but I don't think so it's gonna
be a white chick and an asian chick or a
black shirt and these are not have to
hire a proper get the Verizon Wireless
commercial one of everything one of the
reason these are the goal and they're
like oh J did and he's gonna get off
with sexual misconduct he might for six
months in county jail I'm telling you
this right now that's those are the
hardest things to prove especially we
get a woman asking questions in the
trial some chick that's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that 20 abortions that don't give a [ __ ]
about don't give a [ __ ] cuz she's
aborted them themselves would I have got
call hanger still in the vagina
she got hangers she don't give up that's
what Harvey's gonna hire one of those
chicks is gonna call these [ __ ] out
the best money's not break it down for
me when did they rape you hi listen I
have a daughter I was raised by a single
mom I love women
this is the realities of life these are
the realities of this country
we already got a pigeon we already got
cosmic we set out market cosmic okay we
gave time to what 20 years life
what did he get I thought was only a
couple years but he's so old yeah he's
so dying [ __ ] prison he can't see
sorry getting [ __ ] meats thrown at
him Lizzie yeah I did a joke somebody
threw meet Adam three to ten
he'll get three because a result page
but three is really a year-and-a-half
before he comes back for reconsideration
and they pay a ton of money I think he
just went in there with the wrong
representation and the wrong attitude if
you go in there for a pyramid three
women especially we got deep pockets
like that now already pointed wala reach
and that's exactly what Harvey's up do
benjin you could see it already you
could see what Benjamin Bratt would ask
for it's a setup
he asked for dismissal of all charges
you gotta be crazy but he's already
asking because he's letting them know
listen I'm gonna spare you a lot of
drama and all these chicks all these
chicks gotta come in and all these
attorneys are gonna fry them and guess
what they're gonna hire prosecutors and
they're gonna want all this to every guy
you slept with in the last ten [ __ ]
years and they don't even talk to those
guys and that's a lengthy process this
is a process and the lady that Lydia
holds the scales that [ __ ] got a boring
fall bug Sandra Bullock and that's why
write that [ __ ] got a blindfold on so
like I feel bad I have a daughter all I
could do is educator and prepare for
barracudas
right like that that's all you're doing
never kid right banned them for the
evils of the [ __ ] world and the best
way that you can you know I'm happy that
you said something I'm happy that well
you know I again Jonah I just at the end
of the day we're comedians to think we
should like when you start telling
people that these are jokes we shouldn't
do and you're that big you are affecting
people like me where I'm not like the
biggest comic in the world you know I'm
blessed if any clubs let me play I mean
I'm playing I'm working I'm working more
ever have but I'm blessed if anybody
lets me play right but you empower the
meek they see you saying all this is you
can't do these jokes so now they go to
comedy clubs and they're gonna sit there
and they're gonna get offended because
they don't like the joke and either
they're gonna start yelling and
screaming and disrupt the show or
they're gonna go complain to the manager
because they just didn't like a joke
because Judd Apatow said that's lazy bla
bla bla and it has real effect on that
man you know it's like I get maybe that
you didn't like the subject matter or
maybe you don't like Lucy Kay as a
person but as a comedian you should
fight tooth and nail to be able to say
whatever you want as an art even if
you're not the edgy I don't care if
you're a prop comic I don't care if
you're a tool a [ __ ] a cruise comic
you got to fight to be able to say
whatever you want because you never know
what's gonna piss the mob off they went
after Melissa feeis in York the nicest
human being on the [ __ ] planet they
went after her when she was trying to
get inside her life I jumped in the mix
on that that's why I do I love [ __ ]
doing it because I don't give a [ __ ]
anymore
I'm so happy where I'm at I don't give a
[ __ ] about the industry I don't give a
[ __ ] about any of that stuff I like you
so when they go after my friends I like
to go and like just go straight up whack
Amole doc you know get in there and just
start [ __ ] jacking fools and they
were trying to say she's a racist I'm
like she's the nicest person ever and
she bangs black guys I mean like I don't
know what is more not racist than the
you know the bang a black guy okay why
are you going and like now she's killing
it on the show but they wanted her head
on a stake you have to push back it's
like dude they're they're applying rules
to comedy that they don't apply anywhere
else I mean look at look at like murder
murder is a giant entertainment thing my
favorite murder wonderful podcast number
two podcasts that is making money and
that is comedy off of death I don't get
it and women love murder every
commercial on [ __ ]
the first 48 is [ __ ] Tampax
commercials because women love murder
but yet you're telling me like I can't
do joke you're watching a murder podcast
that is having fun with somebody dying
and it's a great podcast and they should
do it well podcast that's called my
favorite murder it's a it's the number
two podcasts on iTunes
it's a great show I'm not trying to say
it what is it about they just basically
break down I guess like every like they
just talk about murder cases and people
love that [ __ ]
women love murder cuz it's like the
ultimate form of emotion right but it's
like what's it like if you hate
entertainment that's mean that and if
you belittle situation I could have real
world ramifications then why do you go
to horror films horror films people get
murdered or slashed and killed in
everything but you go there to be
entertained why do you do that
murder is real nobody's ever gone to a
comedy show and went on a crime spree
alright it just doesn't happen
lighten the [ __ ] up just because you
don't like a joke doesn't mean it's
offensive move on and I do a bit right
now if you get a friend by joke your
life's going too easy
you got a too [ __ ] easy I don't even
give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] I really
don't give a [ __ ] what jokes don't you
want me to do I'm doing jokes on them I
don't even think about it and you know
it's working dude the pushback is
happening the meek its these betas it's
all [ __ ] betas don't get me started on
[ __ ] trust fund kids in Hollywood
it's all beta [ __ ] I don't I don't
really give a [ __ ] about audiences
that's the only way you to be a
successful cop you're offended good your
life that's an emotion emotion enjoy you
come to one of my shows and you get
upset you're never gonna because you
wouldn't be listening for the podcast
but it's just really crazy that I don't
after that I shot the left Lee special I
made that decision on the plane ride
back from Vegas I was done hard in the
paint dude I'm done I don't give a [ __ ]
I've been doing it for 20 hour and my
stripes I'm saying whatever the [ __ ] I
want to say we don't want to come to the
show don't come to the show switch the
channel
I'm wild with that I'm a big boy yeah
I'm a big boy now I'm fine with that
comedy's the only thing that everybody's
supposed to like it music movies and for
the first 10 years of my comedy career I
used to get kind of jealous of you said
you like Sam Tripoli something that one
day I would like to a [ __ ] what do I
give a [ __ ] I mean if you like a good
comic I'm living with you if you tell me
you like Gallagher trust me I won't call
you back yeah you won't gonna call back
from me ever you know I give you don't
like the comic don't think it's funny
I'm not goofing on calendar you know I
love Gallagher [ __ ] slice new
tomatoes dude he had some great job yeah
but no and just saying that my worries
when you're not a fan of comedy now you
don't know what comedian is I gotta ask
yourself you know or you think a TV show
is the funniest thing you ever saw in
your life like a scripted show on NBC I
can't talk to you or any other network
for that sense we couldn't agree more
like a PG show or something I can't
agree with you it's just becoming its
own weird kind of like like mainstream
entertainments just becoming its own
weird niche now and the Internet has
allowed us to go peer-to-peer and they
get rid of this kind of suits that would
determine what we would say and now
people are getting the truth and they
prefer it much yes you'll always have
people who love America's Got Talent
you know it is what it is it's great
god bless him okay it's not for me but
the more and more people are coming and
what we like and they like dude I was
watching Brian Holtzman last night again
and I was watching people going crazy
for him and I'm like oh comedy is
starting to change
they want the truth they they're tired
of the whiners and the crying and the
and you know that guy at Columbia like
duty is playing a giant room of people
all three people decided to end is set
three for the whole room the whole room
went up to him and pologize them after
because three people felt that they had
they had the power and their meek
[ __ ] okay you don't like a joke
[ __ ] it move on okay move the [ __ ] on
there's another joke coming I got a
jokes for days on everything you'll get
what you came for
okay did they get Madame's there's a
Marklin joke specifically yeah I used I
think that was more about how like this
these kids are now parading all over the
place and you know and they're trying to
make it's like trust me that David Hogg
is you're not punching down on that kid
and I hate that punching down which is a
white chick tour white chicks say well
hey check your white privilege and
punching up they love it because they
hear it it's a just a sickness that's
put out in the mainstream media and they
hear it and they just regurgitate it
later and it's just ridiculous punching
up or punching up you don't know me you
don't know anything you don't know who's
up and who's [ __ ] down right go [ __ ]
yourself
you don't know where I've come from or
how hard I had the [ __ ] work to tell
check my white privilige dude I've been
pulled over [ __ ] 20 times by the LAPD
dude what am i bad driver is it racial
profiling
I'll [ __ ] know it sucks it sucks for
everybody is their racial is their
[ __ ] institutional racism in the law
yes there is but dude it sucks for
everybody
stop with the [ __ ] it and it's it's
white chicks dude they just love to go
[ __ ] nuts they just love to get
offended on other people's behalfs you
know it's like you do joke about [ __ ]
they're like their cousin was a roommate
with a [ __ ] in college and if they
were here they'd be [ __ ] offended
right always always I use a Chinese guy
I open the show every on the road I go
before the show me the other comics we
prayed through comedy gods please help
us make white women over 40 laugh
because that's the number one Democrat
for
to talk to the management and I kind of
like nip it right there nip it and you
see and just kind of walk off of with
there you know k +8 haircut that they
got it super cuts you know something you
don't like a joke who gives a flying
[ __ ]
I don't like every song written by
everybody I of the bands I love there's
some annoying songs it doesn't matter
you tweet at them and tell them I don't
like your song you know what are [ __ ]
you to [ __ ] you don't like the song
don't listen and then it's all listen to
Led Zeppelin what you bothering me if
that's what I do you don't hear me
complaining yeah the music today yeah
under stones I don't even know what the
[ __ ] is going on anymore I don't care I
have my own music I have a [ __ ]
catalogue of music like a different I go
from the Allman Brothers to bob Marathi
I don't even need that I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't know none I don't know
about the word walk I just found that
out
this punch and I don't not that you know
why cuz I don't give a [ __ ] yeah that's
a beautiful place to be not giving a
[ __ ] now I'll be in the moment I care
about that kid I care about doing a good
job on stage and that's it if you don't
like my [ __ ] what can I [ __ ] tell you
move the [ __ ] on trips you have any
dates coming up yes who's there next
long day it's the car it's comedy chaos
double feature 8 8 o'clock and 10:30
Joey Diaz Joe Rogan Whitney Cummings
Chris Spencer myself Eddie Bravo at 8
o'clock and then the 10:50 l Joe Rogan
of course and then the 10:30 show is
myself
Eddie Bravo Brandon job Bryan Callen and
Michael Rapaport and who else is on
there Oh Theo von so that's it and then
19th I'm in New Jersey I'm in Morris
Plains New Jersey I am doing the I'm
doing Tiff's alehouse and I'm super
excited I have some great openers coming
out that is January 19th you go to Sam
triplea.com to get those dates and then
also my special Armageddon
and zero fox are available on Vimeo just
put in Sam Tripoli and you fund them
dude it's a dollar ninety-nine to rent
$2.99 oh I know everybody's fighting for
a dollar so I made it cheap I just want
people to uh you know to check it out
sell the word the word is out the kids
love it it's you know everybody said
nice things about it thank you for being
I love you dude thank you for being a
hustler thank you for sticking this out
it's been a long 20 [ __ ] years but
we're still here Oh every year I'm like
hey dude this is the year but finally if
I got a little traction he'll use a
[ __ ] I'll be in it LaBrea improv at
the end of the month in the 24th through
the 26th get your tickets now it's a big
place was gonna sell out and besides
that I love you [ __ ] all right
I want to thank Sam triply again I want
to thank the number one Christ killer in
the world and I want to thank you guys
for being the best [ __ ] family a man
could [ __ ] am all right I want to
thank Sammy trips I want to thank the
flying [ __ ] Jew but most
importantly I want to thank you guys and
I also want to thank our sponsors I'm
gonna help them out
they helped us out here's the deal all
right for hims calm you're like Joey
what are you talking about listen 66% of
men lose their hair by the age of 35 the
thing is when you start to notice hair
loss it's too late it's easier to keep
the hair you had and to replace the hair
you've lost so if you see that hairline
slowly starting to move backwards you
see any bald spots now is the time to go
to for hims commie like Joey what's for
hims for hims is a one-stop shop for
hair loss skin care and sexual wellness
for men all right hims connects you with
real doctors and medical grade solutions
to treat hair loss well-known generic
equivalents to name but brand
prescriptions to help you keep your hair
and your sexual wellness there's no
snake oil pills or gas station counter
supplements these are prescription
solutions backed by science no waiting
room no awkward person doctor visits you
save hours by going to four hams calm
it's easy you answer a few
questions the doctor review it and then
they prescribe you whatever you need
products are shipped directly to your
door you have to go to the pharmacy and
be embarrassed nothing like that this is
between us go to for hems come right now
what I'm gonna do is this the church
family gets a trial month before hymns
for five hours that's right five hours
this type of treatment will cost you
thousands if you went to a doctor or
pharmacy not at for hymns it's gonna
cost you five hours right now while
supplies last see the website for full
details like I said this would cost you
hundreds if you went to a doctor of
pharmacy I'm gonna save you money
starting off the new year so go to
forums comm slash Joey that's for hims
dot-com slash Joey again for the cheap
seats
that's for hims com slashed Joey the
church is also brought to you by one of
my all-time favorites the zipper cooler
and I'll tell you why
you're gonna kick off tonight 2019 by
planning out which rolls your business
needs to hire for you know what else is
smart starting a new year off strong by
going to zip recruiter comm slash Church
why because you want to hire the right
people to take your business to the next
level
unlike other job sites zip recruiter
finds qualified candidates for you it's
powerful matching technology scans
thousands of resumes to identify people
with the right skills education and
experience and activity invites them to
apply to your job so you get qualified
candidates rapido that means fast and
Spanish that's why zip recruiter is
rated number one by employers in the US
the rating comes from hiring sites on
trust pilot with over a thousand reviews
so what I'm gonna do for you right now
is this the church family can try zip
recruitment you ready for this free fr
EE free zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address you ready grab a
pen zip recruit com slash Church CH you
are CH grab that [ __ ] pen zip
recruiter doc Tom's last Church if you
the show show your support need to hide
the people you need to have good people
in your corner and zip recruiter will
bring them to you so again going to zip
recruiter comm slash Church I want to
thank zip recruiter I want to thank him
I want to thank my people over at allit
comm for making life just for starting a
new year off with a bang with the
protein powders and then the Mexican
chocolate which is delicious just go to
alikom right now I'm pressin Church and
get 10% off delivered right the house
I want that call our sponsors anybody
who's reached out to us but most
important I want to thank you guys for
listening it's the beginning of the year
guys this is it all [ __ ] the gloves
come back on and we're going to [ __ ]
fight it's over
write your goals down focus and let's
make 2019 the best year yet
I love you [ __ ] with all my
heart like I said I'll be in Brea from
the 24th to the 26th of January beside
dying doing dick I'm just doing the
podcast and stand-up around town I love
you guys I'll see you Thursday morning
bright and early ready to [ __ ] kick
the world in the balls by the way
tonight we're not closing with Tony
Bennett I heard this song the other
night when I was on date night with my
wife and I can't believe it's such a
brilliant song I think it was written by
the same guy who wrote lady and when I
don't Richie did it
I just wanted to switch it up it's not
the wrong podcast you got the right
podcast to church or what's happened now
see you [ __ ] Thursday morning
ready to rock stay black I love you and
that's it I have a great [ __ ] week
back
that's it [ __ ] does the holidays
are over wash your [ __ ] it's time to
get back to work kick that [ __ ] mule
Lee